un rugbyman du stade toulousain au pays
des footballeurs sofiane guitoune
travail avec maxence piaule et
préparateur physique du centre médical
de clairefontaine accélération sur 20
mètres changements d'appuis et de
vitesse des exercices pour solliciter
les adducteurs du sportif l'objectif
était vraiment de le recentrer sur ses
sensations et pour voir si lui santé un
déséquilibre au niveau du cycle des gens
mois antérieur sofiane guitoune 28 ans
trois quarts polyvalent du stade
toulousain 5 sélections dans le quinze
de france une participation aux jeux
olympiques de rio en 2016 avec l'équipe
de france à 7
depuis plusieurs semaines il effectue sa
rééducation au centre médical de
clairefontaine après avoir contracté une
pubalgie il ya deux ans il se fait
opérer une première fois en début
d'année à la paroi abdominale
malgré l'intervention la douleur est
toujours présente du coup quand je me
suis fait opérer à fin avril le
chirurgien m'a parlé de clairefontaine
et c'était possible de venir faire sa
rééducation ici et que voilà quoi
c'était c'était le domaine des footeux
que
il avait l'habitude de soigner ce genre
de blessure pubalgie c'est vraiment une
blessure difficile à gérer il ya des
hauts et des bas et il faut faire avec
c'est jamais tout rose et voilà la
semaine dernière ça est très très bien
début de semaine c'était un peu
compliqué là ça va mieux après le
terrain place au renforcement musculaire
une rééducation d'une trentaine d'heures
par semaine suivie de près par le staff
du stade toulousain
une harmonisation des charges de travail
entre le centre médical de
clairefontaine et le club des soins pour
une meilleure récupération à la fois
s'occuper de ses parois et cd de ses
adducteurs
donc le but c'est vraiment de
réharmoniser la zone le centre médical
existe depuis onze ans on retrouve des
consultations pour tous les sportifs
qu'ils soient amateurs ou professionnels
la section rééducation destiné aux
sportifs de haut niveau
priorité aux footballeurs mais pas
seulement rugbyman basketteurs
handballeurs ou même danseur de
breakdance
donc on essaye voilà d'avoir de la
diversité est ce qui est intéressant
pour tout le monde aussi bien pour nous
pour varier un petit peu le type de
pathologie le type d'exercice à mettre
en place
le séjour de sofiane guitoune à
clairefontaine se termine ce jeudi 13
juillet reprise de l'entraînement avec
le stade toulousain à la fin du mois